hey 42 here you probably think that what
your family does at Christmas is a bit
weird but I promise you that's nothing
compared to these unbelievably bizarre
traditions from around the world from
tossing babies at the top of a temple to
literally walking with the dead these
traditions will give your quiet family
Christmas a run for its money I'm sure
you've heard tales of tribes secret
societies and fraternities that have
strange humiliating and sometimes
painful initiation ceremonies well for
years the satyr Amara tribe of the
Amazon rainforest have been looking down
at such rituals and thinking that's cute
because nova society tribe or
civilization has his painful an
initiation or coming-of-age ritual as
these guys when a young boy comes of age
in a satire mera tribe before he can
become a man in the eyes of his fellow
tribesmen and women he must prove
himself to do that he must insert both
his hands into specially made gloves
containing an angry hive of the most
painful stinging animal on earth the
bullet of this little deviant sting is
30 times worse than a bee sting in fact
they are called bulletins because the
pain of their sting is said to be
similar to a bullet hitting your flesh
Justin Schmidt an expert on insect
stings and author of the Schmidt sting
pain index ranked the sting of the
bullet ant as the most painful in the
world
Schmidt described the pain as pure
intense brilliant pain like walking over
flaming charcoal with a free inch nail
in your heel just imagine that for a
second
ouch now imagine sticking your hands
into gloves filled with hundreds of
these little devils whilst they
repeatedly sting you for 10 minutes but
apparently even that's not man enough
for the Chiefs of the satire merit right
the poor boy has to repeat this
agonizing ritual 20 times over the
course of an entire day before he is
truly considered a man never mind a man
anyone who can withstand that deserves
to be king of the bloody Amazon in my
opinion next we go to Japan come on you
knew the Japanese were going to be
somewhere on this list specifically to
kawasaki we're on the first Sunday of
April every year the locals host a penis
festival known to the Japanese is
kanamara matsuri this festival is meant
to celebrate fertility and the power of
the penis the festival started in 1977
and was relatively small but it has
enlarged significantly in popularity in
recent years and has become somewhat of
a tourist attraction during the events
there were a whole range of phallic
activities to participate it you can
make penis candles enjoy a penis shaped
lollipop try your hand at carving a
penis out of a rabbit or just pose of a
giant penis on your head the highlight
of the festival as our parade in which a
giant pink penis known as Elizabeth is
carried around the streets by
transgender and cross-dressing Japanese
festival participants of course there's
plenty of penis related merchandise
available to purchase as well it may
look silly but it's all for a good cause
as well as its symbolic meanings in
recent years all the proceeds from the
festival have been donated to HIV
research remember that person you had a
crush on in school Keamy dreamt of
eloping with well though many gypsies do
more than just dream about it if they
like a girl they simply take her it's a
very old and highly illegal tradition
known as bride kidnapping and it's
practiced frequently in Romani
communities all around the world where
it is seen as completely normal and
acceptable even by today's standards
basically the rules are is so if a man
likes the look of a woman even if he has
never met her before
he can forcibly kidnap her if he can
then keep her by his side for three days
without her escaping she officially
becomes his wife at least in the eyes of
the romeny community this practice is
more formally known as marriage by
abduction the practice is also carried
out by some tribes in Central Asia and
but surely the bride and her family
don't approve of this new union between
woman and her possibly psychopathic new
husband who just subdued her of
chloroform only three days earlier
well since the tradition is so deeply
imbued within the community
the bride and her family usually just
accept her new fate and she simply has
to learn to love her new partner
kidnapping is a hundred percent illegal
when most governments never prosecute
individuals for bride kidnapping because
it's a cultural tradition of an ethnic
minority and outlawing cultural
traditions is not an easy thing to do
and often results in somewhat of a PR
nightmare most traditions have a purpose
to them some kind of hidden meaning melt
this one I present to you the world's
most pointless tradition La Tomatina an
annual tomato fight in the Valencian
town of Brunel in Spain on the last
Wednesday of August every year a huge
crowd gathers in the town and then comes
the most bizarre initiation ceremony to
ever begin a food fight a huge greased
up poll is erected with a ham on top the
tomato fight doesn't officially begin
until someone is able to climb to the
top of the pole and knock the ham up you
couldn't even make this stuff up once
the ham is dislodged from its greasy
pole all hell breaks loose and
contestants love tomatoes at each other
while spectators shower them with water
from hoses but how did this sheer lunacy
originate the story goes that in 1945 a
group of young people went to a parade
in the town and was so excited that they
knocked a parade participant of their
float the participant was so enraged
that they went to a nearby vegetable
store and threw Tomatoes it's everyone
in a fit of rage chaos ensued and
eventually the police had to break up
this massive vegetable fight but the
people enjoyed it so much that they
returned to do the exact same thing on
the same day - the following year and
once again had a food fight of epic
proportions so yeah there really isn't
any point to it
but who cares it looks like fun for the
past 500 years
Indians have been choking babies off the
top of 15 meter high temples in a ritual
known as baby tossing or baby throwing
but don't worry they're not complete
Psychopaths the baby is caught at the
bottom in a large cloth okay it's still
insane
but there is some method behind the
madness the ritual is believed to bring
luck prosperity and health to the
newborn baby most babies are under two
years old when they undergo this
barbaric treatment the so moany start of
the newborn baby's parents saying a
prayer at the temple a large crowd then
gathers and a priest stood at the top of
the temple shakes the baby before
throwing them onto the cloth below the
crowd then cheers and the baby is passed
around before being returned to its
parents Charles rights campaigners have
been trying to get this tradition banned
for years funerals can be expensive and
families don't always have the funds
available to pay for a burial when a
loved one passes away so what do you do
well the taraji people of Indonesia have
a very unique way of dealing with this
if they can't afford a burial the corpse
is instead dressed in guards and placed
in a temporary coffin inside the
family's house the family then lives
with the dead relative until they can
save up enough money for a proper burial
when this time comes do they simply pick
up the coffin and carry it to its new
resting place oh no that's no fun they
instead raise the corpse of its
temporary coffin and ceremoniously walk
the cadaver to its final resting place
which could be miles away giving a whole
new meaning to life after death the Dani
tribe also Familia neva
have a less disturbing but more gruesome
way of dealing with the death of a loved
one they amputate their fingers or get
one of their family members to amputate
it for them when a loved one passes away
relatives of the dead cut the upper part
of their finger or sometimes multiple
fingers off this is meant to be a
physical manifestation of the emotional
pain at the mourner is feeling it is
their way of showing their grief
for the deceased the amputation is done
by first
buying a piece of string tightly around
the finger for 30 minutes to halt the
flow of blood a relative of the mourner
then snips the top half of the finger or
fingers off the new end of the amputees
fingers are then burned in a fire to
create scar tissue and prevent
infections it is usually the women in
the tribe more so than the men who
undergo this barbaric treatment I pet
the movies in that tribe are extra
careful not to ever lose sight of their
children because if anything unfortunate
does happen to them that is going to cut
mummy's fingers off the Chinese have a
peculiar wedding custom before a
newlywed couple can cross the threshold
of their new home for the first time the
husband must carry his wife on his back
over a smouldering bed of hot coals the
ritual is meant to ensure that the wife
will have an easy unsuccessful labor
next up I'm afraid is another macabre
death ritual the yanomamö
tribe in Venezuela and Brazil believes
that burying a body after death and
leaving them to decay is a truly
horrifying prospect so corpses are
cremated as quickly as possible after
death okay that all seems pretty normal
well I'm afraid this is where things get
weird the tribe believes that by
ingesting the remains of a loved one
their spirit will live within them
forever yes I did just say ingest that's
right the yanomamö tribe consumes the
ashes of their dead relatives after
cremation the corpses ashes and bones
are crushed into a powder and mixed into
a plantain soup chowder anyone the ash
and bone soup is then shared around the
tribe and eaten YUM and finally I
wouldn't leave you on such um a carved
note would I let's cheer ourselves up by
going to Russia obviously it's no secret
that the Russians love vodka former
Russian leader Peter the Great who
reigned in the 1700 s used to greet
every foreign diplomat with a 1.5 liter
jug of vodka and required that the
diplomat finished the entire thing to
prove their trustworthy
so it will come as no surprise that the
Russians have their own traditional
drinking game that involves you guessed
it lots and lots of vodka the game is
simply called man down and participants
must stand in a circle each wielding a
bottle of vodka the goal is simple keep
drinking until someone falls over or
passes out and you must drink refusing
to drink is considered an insult
sounds like a super fun way to get
alcohol poisoning thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
you